the our universe and all that and all
the universe that ever existed that we
have gotten to this point before and
that we this might be the eighth or some
people believe the ninth existence do
you recall why they specifically said
eight or like here's what they I why I
don't know why they said eight or nine
that I I don't know I was uh spotting a
guy at the gym and he was talking to me
about this uh press and press bench
press how many how many reps he's a
strong guy he did about he did about 10
at at 270. when you put your hand on
that do you ever lift more than you let
on to give them a little confidence I
try to be honest with them but sometimes
I could you know he was he was a race
for man clearly on steroids yelling me
about when the universe began so I
wanted to just tell him I didn't barely
touch him I'm just guiding you by the
way when you're bet when you're spotting
a guy at the bench press there's no way
to not teabag him yeah you're always
teabagging yeah and you just have to
accept that or at least it's too close
for comfort your testes and his forehead
your balls are the closest to another
man's forehead they might ever be unless
you're a gay man right